hello and welcome to this video aqaba in
the house again I get the same guys with
the same color every time this guy I
always play with black and really
Hendrix are always playing with black as
well IAM at this time it doesn't play
squash I can I usually play sasquatch
not this time so we have a Vienna game
in store ok interesting I will cancel
short yet ok maybe can so long why not
so dangerous before I for might be but I
have define a map I have come to claim
the center i think i want to actually if
GF is something that i could claim my
google takes gtx h form it's not
entirely clear to me d file is also not
clear where this is something that I
should do maybe see 675
charlie is he putting some pressure now
on the sender this one okay I I think he
someone has to play for you playing for
c4 okay let's do this first see he
should play for see for now I guess I
mean otherwise it looks pretty okay for
black or not some some be 39 f or maybe
mmm okay so I'm threatening g5 now and
98 the 96 to see form that looks pretty
pretty bad for white i see now i'm
already sucking on a seven or something
like that maybe now that doesn't work
actually not not not well at least okay
instead as the dirty desperation mode
already so what to do now i see this
till his son doesn't have many squares
for the night Queen to e6 he actually
will sacrifice on a seven-play 96 that
does work in 96 is an idea for him I can
go queen to d6 that was my original
intention actually I can still take her
harm
hmm so I'm not seeing it wrong he said
it indeed something for white it would
be extremely weird 96 you having that
you think there's an eye is an issue
online i'm sick of this that's it's due
this year man drooped g8 if it takes it
you will probably take on e 79 play 965
to confuse me can't think i should have
some kind of a techie as well 1g three
maybe and ice queen up to f4 is this
idea I can't put the King on the side
first and then see okay I can also go
Nancy for it and let's do this so
checking here clock let's check
right therefore I don't have I don't
have a tactic yeah don't have any tactic
can take the four-week f-18 g3 save some
can take III does it help ok threatening
96 now maybe pin that I wonder no I
cannot do that actually I was thinking
what if I return the exchange but it's
not a great idea mmmm I would like to
trade this out with 96 but I don't quite
see if this is possible mmm now that his
Queen might might enter my position here
Queen a 5 and so on no it's not not send
Ian home ok so he allows this move very
surprised very surprised
so I get to trade the Knights long does
he go to h 5 9 h 5 looks very strange to
put it on the edge of the board no this
is this idea okay 24 or what's the deal
anyway anyway this is attacked this is
also attacked and Quincy five so if i go
here hi morning i might mc3 right the
right moment Pleasance to take their
with the queen or not no okay i should
speed up here definitely
you should check so what my idea is now
queen bee to oxy one maybe it's just
going to show g2 or something yeah it's
not that easy because cannot cannot move
quickly but okay maybe just this entry
can be too I don't see how I'm winning
here necessarily check
okay check check check go to check
seconds here crazy it's not super easy
check check check check check no check
no black 45 Oh goddamn it really this is
crazy this is getting crazy here I mean
what okay okay let's stay cool here Zach
everything's great I mean you know I'm
screwing up the screen okay I mean yeah
I can do everything I was just thinking
okay let's win this on time now with a
few quick pre moves and I don't know I
know everything okay it's sick to
analyze him okay the game yeah the game
was a bit strange because right here my
decision just doesn't make much sense
after you for yeah white is already in
serious trouble if you don't believe me
switch on the bloody thing here he has
misplaced his might all these pieces are
bad yeah and it was necessary at all
okay he went into a desperation more
quickly a night h5 was quicker winning
and this isn't actually all that clear I
mean it was clear to me that he would
sacrifice but I was just thinking it it
it doesn't work anyway but it does work
some somewhat at least this means
immediately threatening g5 and
threatening this year
g3 so yeah if he takes actually here I
can do this and there are no tactics i
can also attack here and whatever okay
so it's actually kind of a miracle that
this is still a position for white I
think but ok it is working I now return
to pawn to untangle this is this is
really funny because now I have no
square for the Queen to get to catch
this I mean I can trap it but that
failed to outlandish to me to play like
that as so that I can trap it but then
does this look far more natural to
ejaculate and here this is still kind of
playable it ok come here there is no
sacrifice raining and yeah then here now
to see 3 and so on no again I should win
but I didn't didn't quite quite manage
until I won the Queen I mean here this
is just a mess with 20 seconds yeah okay
I don't know how I screw that up kind of
a bad bad day I think and just did
nothing works if you haven't won a game
in the whole session like the fifth game
in a row need only it kind of sucks
victim yeah I mean losing anyway guys
thanks for watching